breaking right now for CCSD students
arrested after five guns were recovered
on three separate campuses and at a home
now here's the breakdown two weapons
were recovered from students at El
Dorado High School another discovered at
Mojave High School after a family member
reported a gun was stolen from the home
and yet
another disturbing day Joshua hello
Kirsten Brian the weapons taken today
bring the total number of handgun sees
this school year within CCSD to 37. it's
a concerning number considering 31
handguns were seeds over the course of
the entire school year in 2021-2022 now
25 of the guns were taken from school
buildings while 12 were recovered from
property near the school this averages
out to one gun recovered every three
school days CCSD police officer
Association releasing a statement it
reads every firearm recovered was in
possession of a child or a person that
could not lawfully possess the firearm
every firearm recovered represents a
very real threat to the safety of
students to staff at the school and the
office who in the officer who had to
recover it the district is also
encouraging parents to be aware of what
their child is taking to school and to
secure any guns in the house reporting
live in The Newsroom Joshua peguero
eight news now thank you Joshua CC csdpd
also telling us they will investigate a
crime that originates at a school and
may lead to a house that's why one
weapon was likely recovered from a home
we will